well the leader of the liberal Democrats
Davey has called on Mr Rob to go one
step further than resigning from cabinet
Dominic Rabb has shown himself not only
unfit to be a minister but also to be a
member of parliament he should resign
and trigger a by-election here in Isham
Walton so his constituents can get the
MP they deserve I'm here in eastern
Walton and I've been talking to lifelong
conservatives who are switching away
from the conservatives to the liberal
Democrats and in many places like this
across the country they are angry that
the conservative government has let them
down so badly over things like the cost
of living and the NHS crisis Tori MPS
taking their communities for granted and
in many areas like this people know that
if they want to get rid of the
conservatives they need to vote liberal
Democrat and get a real true champion
for their community